aujourd'hui Brahim vous vous êtes
syndicative VTC est-ce qu'il y a souvent
il y a beaucoup de cas comme ça bah
écoutez on a appris cet après-midi déjà
que le mouvement uber servover reprend
on a des agressions sexuelles qui ont
été déclarées cet après-midi sur les
plateformes hitch et Hubert donc
agression client et chauffeur bah
maintenant finalement il y a de la
sécurité on a banalisé ça pendant des
années moi j'avais averti du coup
j'avais proposé des solutions et là
c'est devenu affluent donc moi je pense
que là si on fait pas quelque chose et
comprend pas des mesures tout de suite
j'ai peur qu'on arrive à un drame quoi
est-ce qui arrive à Anthony ça c'est
choquant c'est choquant alors
apparemment ils auraient été retrouvés
les deux personnes
agresser apparemment c'est ce qu'on dit
c'est ça qu'ils auraient été retrouvés
on va voir mais ce couple est connu
apparemment des des services de police
apparemment c'est pas la première fois
qu'ils font ça je confirme c'est ça vous
étiez au courant oui en fait nous on a
su il y a des personnes qui se sont
déclarés aussi donc c'était le même
couple avec des fois différentes
personnes et la plateforme Bolt n'a
jamais pris l'initiative de les
déconnecter donc du coup là il y a des
enquêtes en cours je peux pas trop
parler mais voilà on verra ce qui va se
passer c'est pas la première fois qu'ils
font ça non d'accord il y a eu
énormément d'agressions de de VTC ou pas
il y a eu beaucoup je vais vous raconter
une anecdote il y a on a une console une
fois même chose même procédé on l'a
amené dans un coin paumé elle était
braquée à l'armure on lui a pris son
téléphone on l'a frappé violemment elle
était traumatisée à ce jour un exercice
plus
et c'est une femme je l'ai accompagné on
a réussi à obtenir une compensation
financière de la plateforme c'est
dérisoire quoi par rapport au préjudice
ça a été quoi la compensation je vais
être honnête avec vous c'était 6000
euros pour moi et encore 6000 euros
parce que c'est même pas prévu dans les
conditions d'utilisation de la
plateforme c'est vraiment j'ai essayé
d'aller accompagner demander au moins
quelque chose mais c'est très difficile
de les attaquer sur la responsabilité
même les avocats refusent ils disent que
voilà il faut vraiment des éléments
parce que c'est une plateforme
d'intermédiation voilà Anthony
aujourd'hui vous nous avez dit que vous
alliez mettre un petit peu de temps à
à reprendre le travail vous habite à
Lille
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que franchement
on se met on se met à sa place on se dit
c'est compliqué de reprendre et moi
quand je vois j'ai vu les deux là leur
comportement vers Anthony même chez je
vous jure je supporte plus ce genre de
vidéo oui mais les images sont
extrêmement choquantes et quand on voit
ça on se dit que il y a peut-être tout
le système des VTC à revoir parce qu'il
y a de plus en plus d'agressions de
chauffeurs de plus en plus d'agressions
de passagers je crois qu'il y a de moins
en moins de chauffeurs parce que les
conditions de travail se dégradent
malheureusement les gens ne veulent rien
payer ni les chauffeurs ni les courses
donc ça crée des tensions est-ce que
c'est pas tout le modèle des VTC qu'il
faut revoir selon vous moi je vais vous
répondre ça fait des années que
justement je défonce secteur on a assez
fait tellement voir clairement ou je
vais répondre à votre question n'a pas
eu le temps une fois quand j'étais venu
on paye une TVA sur les 25% de la
commission Aubert est-ce que c'est
normal qu'aujourd'hui on doit payer à la
place du Berre est-ce que c'est normal
qu'aujourd'hui on nous impose une
tarification on nous dit c'est comme ça
vous voulez vous voulez pas on vous
déconnecte du jour au lendemain on nous
dit que ça crée de l'emploi non ça crée
du chômage parce que je peux vous dire
qu'il y a des personnes qui ont exercé
deux trois mois et qui sont déconnectés
à tort et le pire dans cette histoire là
c'est qu'il y a rien qui va on est dans
une société de où nous surveille parce
que dans la plateforme ce qu'on a
découvert c'est effrayant c'est que nous
filmons notre insu on les écoute à notre
insulte nos données personnelles par
ailleurs il y a tout à revoir on veut
sécuriser ça va pas aujourd'hui il y a
une directive européenne qui est portée
pour justement améliorer les conditions
de travail il y a des lobbyings de
malades et pour terminer j'étais tout à
l'heure au Parlement européen je reviens
donc du Parlement je retrouve valobistes
qui disent mais ils sont il y a la
flexibilité ils peuvent travailler à
tout moment alors je pose la question à
Tony aujourd'hui Anthony qui a subi cet
accident là il vit de quoi pas de
protection bien sûr pas les moyens
justement finalement de financer quoi
que ce soit et il se retrouve
excusez-moi au chômage technique et il
pourra vous gagnez
en fait il y a des des histoires un peu
farfelues des mythes mais en réalité si
on revient sur l'article d'un coup la
Cour des comptes beaucoup de chauffeurs
ne déclare pas parce qu'ils savent même
pas comment fonctionne la déclaration
URSSAF vous voyez il y en a qui voilà un
chauffeur franchement honnêtement ça
dépend il y a des périodes il y a des
périodes où en moyenne en moyenne ça
peut être par exemple à Paris on est sur
2000 € de chiffre d'affaires pour 80 €
de 80 heures de connexion donc ça fait
en moyenne avec toutes les charges et
tout à peu près 1003400 donc voilà parce
que ils sont en propriétaire de leur
véhicule lui ce qui a pas mal de charges
le carburant dans le carburant est-ce
qu'on s'en sort quand on est chauffeurs
VTC ou pas non on s'en sort mais on fait
plus d'heures pour pour moins moins de
chiffre d'affaires donc ça